皆さんは去年東京オリンピックをご覧に
なられましたか
ご覧になられた方も多いしていた競技は
ありますか
[音楽]
私はバスケットボールやテニス
バトミントンをすごく応援していました
ところでメダリストがうれし涙を流し
ながらインタビューに答える姿もよく見
ますよね
私はこのような映像を見るたびに一つ疑問
に思うことがあります
それはうれし涙を流す理由です
なぜ嬉しいことが起きているのに涙を流し
ているんだろうといつも気になっていまし
た
しかし今ではその理由が少しわかったよう
な気がします
てリスを通して私はそれ
その理由を知ることになりました
face は小さい頃からやっている
スポーツで負けず嫌いだった私は今もそう
です
一生懸命レッスンに励んでいました
去年高校に入学した時に1週間後に遠征
チームに入るための試合を控えていました
1週間後
友達に友達と
コートに向かいながら
衛星 g 6に入ったらどんな学校と対戦
するんだろうなどと衛星チームに入った
前提で話を進めていたのを覚えています
いざ
コートに立って
試合を始めると頭が真っ白になり手足も
すごい快適ためテニスラケットを落とした
ことも何回かありました
結果試合に一つも勝つことができず
コーチに今年はレギュラーチームで頑張っ
てね
言われてしまいました
その時
無数のバラの棘が心に刺さったように胸が
痛みました
気づけば
てリースコートに水溜りができるほど
悔し涙を流してしまいました
その後
レギュラーチームとして練習が始まった私
は隣のコートから聞こえてくる衛星チーム
に入った友達の払いゴンや笑顔が引くだけ
で見るだけで精神的に苦痛でした
次第にレギュラーチームの練習に行くだけ
でも精神的に不安定になり自分はもう
テニスはやっちゃいけないミスには向いて
いないんだと思い始めて思い始めてしまい
長い暗いトンネルの中のような日々を
過ごし始めました
そのような暗い日々を過ごしていたある日
友達に学校に在住
常駐するカウンセラーに会ってみたらどう
と聞かれました
最初何を言っているんだと思っていました
私は自分のことを一番よく理解できている
し
カウンセラーに自分の話をしても意味が
ないと思っていました
しかし友達曰くカウンセラーは想像以上に
精神的に助けてくれると言われたので半信
半疑で会うことを決めました
友達は正しかったです
会って話をすることによって自分は心に
絡まっていた鎖が解けるように
スッキリとした気持ちになれました
この時初めて私は
メンタルヘルスの大雪はを知ることができ
ました
もちろんカウンセラーにあっている時自分
の話だけではなくカウンセラー自身の話や
アドバイスもいろいろとくれました
その中で今でも大切にしているアドバイス
は
ポジティブな考え方です
物事をすべてポジティブのほうに考える
ことによってネガティブの方忘れ少しずつ
日々が明るくなってくることを教えてくれ
ました
実際に私の日も明るくなっていき
テニスにも真剣に向き合うことができまし
た
こうして
カウンセラーと定期的に会うことによって
あっ日々も明るくなり自分はまた
衛星地位便脳がエース a チームの試合
の前のような考え方に合わすことができ
ました
そして1年があっという間に立ち
衛生チームの試合遠征チームに入るための
試合がまた行われました
とても緊張しましたが
美琴私は遠征チームに入ることができまし
た
こうして私は成し遂げたかった目標は達成
することができましたが
メンタルヘルスやカウンセラーがいなかっ
たら達成できなかったと思う
達成できなかったと思います
こちらをご覧ください
これは10代前半の自殺率あー表した
バーグラフでです
見ての通り
102018年が過去100年で一番高い
水
高い自殺率ロア自殺率は表しています
もちろん自殺率が増加した理由には
いろいろあると思いますが気軽に話せる
環境がないことも一つの原因だと私は考え
ます
私の学校にはカウンセラーがいましたが
ほとんどの学校にはそういう人がいないと
思います
もちろん今からすべての学校に
カウンセラーを導入するのはとても難しい
と思います
しかしこれからは日本は精神的健康と進退
的健康が同等に扱われるべきです
同等に扱われることによって
うつにうつ病事業を発症する人も少なく
なり若者の自殺率も下げることができると
私は思います
今日私のプレゼンテーションを聞いていく
くださっている人の中で悩みを抱えている
人がいるかもしれません
その場合はぜひ一歩
雪を出してみてください話してみて
ください
私もそうでした
どんなくらい長いトンネルでも出口は必ず
あります
その出口を目指して自分のペースで歩んで
みてください
以上スピーチを得ますありがとうござい
ました